[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality best-selling
author and host of the ken coleman show
is my co-host today today we'll be
talking to you about your career your
work your relationships your mental
health your money your life
it's all on display right here and we're
going to talk about you right in front
of you the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five cara is with us cara is going to
start off this hour in rhode island hi
kara how are you
hey dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so just um kind of a quick question when
you have
a longer a probably longer than average
time horizon for baby step two that's
where we're on right now um does it
still make sense at that point to
completely pause retirement savings
we're both in our i'm 32 my husband's
33.
um
i'm just wondering because we have about
a hundred and forty thousand dollars
worth of miscellaneous debt not
including our mortgage and
just doing the numbers and everything
it's probably going to be a few years
and we are you know kind of scrimping
and saving and stuff but i just
i my employer does offer me a match on
my uh 401k and i can do a roth so i was
just wondering if
should i just complete
lose out on that time
you know what i mean yes
yes
you need to lose out on that time you
need to completely focus on that there
is a power that is unleashed when you
focus exclusively on something
that is not unleashed when you disperse
your emotions and your spirit across
several things
okay so this complete obsession
this scream and howl at the moon
i'm getting out of that
that's what gets you out of debt
this i'm going to be smart and i'm going
to intellectually figure out all these
things does not get anybody anywhere and
that's why we have a culture of broke
people walking around acting like
they're smart
not you other people you're sweet you
called and asked a question but that's
why all these people are strutting
around with car payments acting like
they're somebody and they're not that's
just straight up stupid and they are
stupid when they're doing that i was
stupid when i did it and so you just
this exclusive focus supersedes the
power of the match and the compound
interest over the scope of your life
because it sets new grooves and habits
and principles into your brain where you
never change what's your household
income
uh we're just we're just under a hundred
thousand okay and how much of the
hundred and forty thousand is car
uh about eighteen thousand
on one car
no i'm too priced okay all right yeah we
had a stupid fleece and you've been
working on this program for a month and
a half maybe what how long
um
no
we we messed up last year
so we
we stopped and we started again
so yes at this point i have like we have
refocused and it's we're probably on
three months now
that's about right that's what i get i
figured you were early in the game yeah
no we are we like seriously
but this time but this time of year
this time you're serious
yes yes
and then you look up and you go i'm
serious and that's a tall freaking
mountain that i'm seriously gotta climb
ouch scary intimidated overwhelmed right
ken yeah i so let's let's help you
really focus here for a second so how
much you contributing to the 401k let's
just do simple math what's coming out of
your check for that
um well
this is why i wanted to call and ask
because i had i had dialed it down to
three percent
so
uh like a hundred bucks 120 bucks that's
fine for this example
so what's your smallest debt you're
familiar with what we teach in baby step
two you take the smallest debt first so
what's your smallest debt round numbers
if you don't know it exactly yeah um no
no no worries um we're fit i'm finishing
up a just a medical bill that was that's
got about 600 bucks left on it all right
so
you're not you know 100 bucks take out
taxes but if you just put a hundred
bucks or 50 bucks a month and you just
attack that medical loan boom you're
done with that what's the next highest
one
it's a uh a lawyer bill for my husband's
student loan that's 1400 bucks right so
those are manageable and as dave's
talking about you guys getting at this
then all of a sudden here's what you're
gonna experience we know this we've
heard this from tens of thousands of
people you're gonna experience momentum
after a couple of those because you go
wait a second we've sacrificed maybe
he's working an extra job we're selling
everything and all of a sudden you get
momentum and that 140 000 isn't so scary
anymore because you see yourself
attacking this thing and we're getting
there we're getting there we're getting
there so being really really disciplined
right now and clear that the process
works you just have to taste a couple of
victories so
here's
let me
if i were to do a weighted
average approach to your situation okay
um
one percent of you succeeding
financially
in the scope of the next 10 years is
whether or not
mathematically is whether or not you do
this match or not
it's a hundred bucks
you can sneeze and lose that
it doesn't matter
let me show you how much it doesn't
matter
okay how many times do you have to do
100 bucks to pay off an 18 000 car a lot
and yet i didn't jump on and sell your
cars
why didn't i do that because as a ratio
of the overall problem they don't fix
the problem this hundred bucks doesn't
fix the problem selling the cars doesn't
fix the problem but what really does fix
the problem 85 to 90 percent of the the
mayonnaise on the bologna sandwich the
thing that makes it work here 85 to 90
percent of the reason you're going to
succeed is your complete focus and sell
out and sticking to this and tearing
into it and working extra and selling so
much stuff the kids think they're next
and not seeing the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
and you're doing the budget and you and
your husband are working and all you're
thinking about for the next 24 to 36
months is i'm getting out of debt and
you know anybody that says anything to
you just yell at him get away from me
you know just do it i'm just doing this
i'm freaking doing this and that's the
people that get out of debt it's not an
intellectual exercise
yeah it's a visceral
roar at the moon coming from down inside
your soul that i freaking had it and i'm
not living like this anymore that's 85
to 95 of this that is represented by
your willingness to quit playing footsie
with the mathematics of a hundred
dollars
yes the emotional representation inside
your
soul
uh that that you gave up this holy match
from your employer that everyone
worships oh my god that's the answer
it's wonderful to get a match by the way
but everybody acts like it's a big thing
the big thing is you
you're the deal you're the secret sauce
personal finance is 80 behavior it's 20
of that knowledge when you get your
emotions your relationships the
psychology of who you are all dialed in
and you go that's it
i've had it i'm sick and tired of being
sick and tired it's when you change your
life baby
it's not when you drop the match or
start the match it's not when you
suddenly understand compound injuries
it's not even when you sell your 18 000
worth of cars out of a hundred forty
thousand debt when you make a hundred
thousand dollars a year
but you'll find a way
when you've had it
and that's the deal
this is the ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
have you ever wondered if an online will
is right for you do you need a trust do
you need a mirror image will what kinds
of powers of attorney do you need uh you
hear me say everyone needs a will but i
get a lot of questions asking if a
simple online will is right for
someone's specific situation with those
questions in mind our team built a quiz
that's free
to help you find the right option for
you the quiz gives you custom results
based on the basic info like if you're
married or single where you live even
the size of your estate it helps you
understand exactly what you need for
your
specific situation take the quiz to find
out what kind of will
you need to properly protect your family
and your wishes go to
ramseysolutions.com
wills
quiz
ramsey solutions dot com slash wills
quiz take the free quiz check it out for
yourself
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five blinds dot com
gives us our question of the day they
have a 100 satisfaction guarantee that
means even if you mismeasure or you pick
the wrong color you'll remake they'll
remake your window blinds for free they
got free samples free shipping and new
promos all the time this is a great
company i bought blinds from them for
our patio not long ago check them out
promo code ramsey you'll get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from elaine in california she writes
i've been working as a commissioned
salesperson for a small family owned
business for two years and have not
received a raise i received lots of
positive feedback from the owner
since cost of living is on the rise i
would like to ask for a raise but i'm
certain excuse me i'm uncertain of how
to determine an appropriate amount to
propose i currently have to meet a 28
000
sales goal before i begin receiving
commission and i gross 950 a week as a
base my fear is that if they increase my
base pay they'll also increase the 28
000 goal how do i evaluate at which
point these adjustments would cancel
each other out and amount to no
financial benefit to me and how do i
start these negotiations well first
thing i'm going to address here dave is
i don't like the word negotiation i know
what she means but i really want this to
take a posture of conversation not
negotiation the other thing is is that
as a guy who has spent a lot of time in
my professional career on commission
in this case i would not be having a
conversation about cost of living um i
would be uh talking about maybe a higher
percentage of commission uh based on
sales goals i would talk about the cost
of living um and i would have some real
facts here and kind of okay here's uh
what's going on this cost has risen this
cost has risen but even then
unless it's something very dramatic and
i'm guessing here i'm trying to read
into this that inflation is really not
what i would call a cost of living rise
even though it is it's like everybody's
facing that you didn't move anywhere
this is not a change in location for a
company to where cost of living is a big
difference so here um i'm i'm gonna sit
put sit tight and focus my conversation
around
how can i increase
my commission rate based on performance
you know i think when you're in a sales
position
you really aren't capped
unless you don't have uh a good product
or good service to sell so your raise is
effective when you are i knew you were
gonna i almost said that way that's your
line yeah i mean yeah
you are when you're on commission you
want to raise
go make more sales yeah
get better at it hello yeah you know and
if you if you work for us and you came
in we would be nice but that's basically
what we would tell you yeah you want to
raise kill more things and drag it home
we share with you what you kill and drag
home get up leave the cave kill it and
drag it home can we help you do that
better sure we'll try to help you do
that better can we furnish you more some
more marketing assets or better leads
we'll try to talk about that anything we
can do there but um at the end of the
day you have the best possible scenario
go sell more
what does that involve what does it take
to make that happen that's right and uh
you know is there some other is there
something that the company has
the product line has
that is a blocker to you selling more i
might ask for them to help lower some of
those blockers
uh you know this computer you gave me
sucks i can't get anything out the
emails inconsistent i can't communicate
with my customers i'm losing sales
because i can't do that we had a phone
system one time that sucked and it was
killing sales
and that's not fair to the salesperson
and a couple of them griped about it and
i'm always a champion the sales guy
because i've been a sales guy my whole
life and so i went hey rip out the
freaking phone system put one in that'll
actually make sales it's driving me nuts
here we're losing that gun money yeah
because here's the thing you're you're
the best thing you will make your
employer smile
you make more sales yeah they don't mind
me of giving you more money by the way
that's how you start that conversation a
thousand dollar a year base too baby
doll yeah i mean she
ain't bad
that's not exactly straight commission
talk to people in the real estate
business and let me tell you what they
make if they sell no houses no money
there is no base
it's called straight commission
and so they be out selling houses is
what they be doing
and
by the way dave i would never ever ever
ever ever ask for more base i'm on
straight
any books i don't make any money yeah i
want more commission ken you're on your
own commission i am actually would you
sell some more books
yes we're working on it but you know the
reality is that people don't understand
that they think they think base equals
security no that's a false that's a
false choice there nope you know you
don't have any problem if you're selling
a million books you don't have any
issues about security no it won't come
up
you know so if you make a million sales
or whatever it is you're doing well you
know it's just it's how we're going to
do more how are we going how are we
going to scale this how much more can i
work what can how can i be more
effective i mean if you got four leads
and you close three of them you don't
have a closing problem you got a lead
problem
how are you going to get more leads if
you got four leads and you close one out
of 100 you got a problem your conversion
rate sucks
so you need to learn to close the sale
you know that this is this is it man
sales is the best business in the world
absolutely it's my favorite career track
for somebody i wish i could talk young
people all i'm into going into sales
because you just control your own
destiny sales people make more than any
other category they make more than
doctors and lawyers that's true
salespeople when you talk to some
medical sales device sales people oh
yeah 300k
pharmaceutical sales 300k car dealers or
car sales people right now here's 150
200k i met a guy the other day that's
just killing it and a very nice guy
we were introduced by mutual friend when
we were done talking i said to my buddy
i go what does he do he's in sales what
does he sell he goes you're not gonna
believe this he sells all those gigantic
like pipes that i don't even want to
call it a pipe but like those giant
cylinders that they put in under roads
when they're doing new roadwork i mean
giant concrete like commercial
construction that guy called thank you
sells those things and is crushing it
sure sure because those are expensive
items
government's paying for them right it's
big money yeah so
it's a great field to go into because
you can control your own destiny
more clearly than you can just about
anything else because someone else
controls the purse strings everywhere
else
but um
my goal is to have sales people around
here
that are making more money than they've
ever made in their life because that
means they're helping more people
they're serving more people than they
ever have in their life that's correct
and um my other goal is for salespeople
that are not doing that to have skinny
kids that's correct that's right and you
want a salesperson that comes to you as
a leader and says hey i want to make
more but i know that i make more when i
make you more how can we do that how can
we do that better touchdown i'll help
you do that they love that i'll do that
all day long by the way that's not a
negotiation it's a conversation
and that's the key possibility basically
that's true of any raise that's correct
because you know how can i make you more
so that i'm worth more yeah so you give
me some of it that's the conversation
how can i get better how can i get more
valuable to the organization so i help
you win as a result i win professionally
corporate america corporate america is
different corporate america is stupid
they're not going to do this stuff
because they get politics and toxic crap
and all this garbage going on but normal
businesses the owner or the manager of
the business would like to bring in more
revenue and if you bring in more revenue
they would love to share it with you so
you do it again
that's the trick i mean when you get
somebody performing you want them to do
it again and again and again and again
and and so that that's normal human
beings are in the business now again
corporate america is stupid they forget
all this stuff and you can't make more
than the guy in the corner office well
bull crap if you sell enough stuff you
can you can have the corner office we'll
kick him out
i mean you know you get her done baby
that sales people are my favorite people
i love them very happy because they're
serving there's no way you can sell a
whole bunch of stuff without serving all
you can on the short term you rip people
off but i'm talking about mo over a
career
you got to help people when you help
people
they they give you certificates of
appreciation with president's faces
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
let's
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
thank you for joining us america ken
coleman ramsey personality host of the
ken coleman show is my co-host today
open phone is a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five
open phones here hey ken triple eight
eight two five five two two five adam is
with us on the debt free stage in the
lobby of ramsey solutions how are you
adam i'm doing well how are you better
than i deserve
where do you live cincinnati ohio oh
cool so good to have you thanks for
watching all the way here to do a
debt-free screen that's right fun how
much did you pay off uh 226 thousand
dollars whoa how long did that take
about two and a half years good for you
and uh your range of income during that
time uh started off about twenty five
thousand dollars
ended up 250. whoa
not a bad jump we'll take it what were
you doing and what do you do i started
off a waiter and now i'm in sales sales
management now just like we were talking
about you set it up that's wow you set
this up perfectly oh man amazing okay
what do you sell uh cars oh there you go
it just said this is so great almost
like we know we're talking about
[Laughter]
way to go man thank you very cool i'm so
glad you're doing so well
you know
i was talking on the way up here with a
friend of mine
a big portion of it is i had to pay off
my debt so i had to sell more cars and
you know it would be great to hang on
the couch and watch netflix or whatever
it might be but it's more important to
pay off the debt yeah and then like ken
was talking about earlier momentum got
on my side
and once the momentum started picking up
speed there was just there's just no
stopping it so what i was saying
when we're talking about all this a
minute ago you can really speak to this
yes my contention has always been that
the best sales people in the world know
how to serve
and you were a server
then you got so all you do is serve
people into buying a car
just help them you just help them
patience thick skin and listen
really so this is fascinating so i love
that formula at what point in this
debt-free journey did you make the move
from waiter too so it's two and a half
years at what point did you move from
waiter to car sales so i
that was the the short story of it but i
started off a waiter and i went to
restaurant management
and uh you know real close to since i
read stadium so i had free red stickers
and free prime rib it was tough to get
me away and my friend was in car sales
and he got promoted to management and he
kept trying to get me to come do it and
then he finally sent me a picture of his
paycheck
thank you and i was there the next day
yes i was in here next time
yep wow good for you man so what kind of
debt was the 226 thousand dollars uh 15
000 was student loans 45 were cars 130
was my mortgage oh oh 30 000 was credit
card and 6 000 was taxes you paid off
your house bye bye
and we're looking at weird dude this is
awesome way to go weirdo you're right
that grass does feel fear it does feel
different on your feet when it's
yours i love it what's this house worth
uh now it's about 250. it was 130
yeah i love it yeah yeah you got a
quarter million dollar paid for
household are you uh 44. wow way to go
man thank you congratulations i'm so
proud of you thank you yeah it's uh it's
a you know uh
this this all started when i decided to
get sober and uh when getting sober you
make amends right and part of making
amends is financial amends
which i thought was gonna be a sidestep
you know because i was sober
and uh everyone else where i was like oh
no no no no no i had a friend co who
would say there's no way i could have
what i have today had i not paid off my
financial amends
my other friend john very shortly after
that showed up
gave me your book and said i'm doing
very very well for myself and i still
follow this man's formula
private idea if you did too wow
wow so are you sober from alcohol or
what uh mainly i'll call yes okay all
right how long you been dry uh eight
years way to go man thank you for you
you're an absolute hero you completely
took control of your life uh well god
did i just i just listened yeah and but
you did it i mean you stuck it out i'm
so proud of him thank you thank you
thank you for your help well done i love
being part of that story of particular
yes yes that's very cool good for you
man thank you all right so now you did
it
you you're successful in that you paid
off
226 thousand dollars for the debt it's
not theory you're an actual practitioner
you actually did it it's not a
discussion with your broke
brother-in-law you really did it
how do you tell people that you got out
of that what's the key to getting out of
debt
uh like you guys said it's not a math
problem it's emotion it's emotion and
um
wanting that more than you want to look
like somebody else
you know it's real easy to want to keep
up with the guy sitting next to me you
know selling cars or you know my friend
that's going on vacation every other
month or whatever it might be i had a
lot of friends with a lot of vacations
that i didn't go on
you know i was at home paying off my
debt and
like you know it's just that thick skin
it's just sitting through it and seeing
to the end and i've made mistakes i mean
i went backwards a couple times you know
it's it's nobody's perfect and but to be
able to shake it off and get back you
know pick yourself up by your bootstraps
and keep marching forward
it was a big part for me i want to ask
you i think it's it's so incredibly
heroic that you have overcome substance
abuse and that addiction and all that
how much did that play in the discipline
and you having to say hey you know what
it took to get through that and stay
clean how much did that come into this
journey
a hundred percent so
i went when john gave me your book i was
in a halfway house
i was living in a park in cincinnati
ohio and i had just started living in a
halfway house
in the part of your book where you talk
about changing your family tree forever
struck home more than anything
you know because i really saw myself at
a point where a decision had to be made
and uh you know at the time i looked at
it and said you know what i'm young
enough where i can change my family tree
forever you know i had my daughter
and um i just went all in
i went all in i really on that statement
that statements that was that's how you
set the hook was with that statement
now so where was your daughter with her
mom at the time correct okay all right
and she's with her with you today yeah
she's right here i love it that's very
cool yeah very powerful stuff and she
got to watch her dad walk this heroic
journey oh yeah it's left an imprint on
her more than the money issue will it it
has very little to do with the money
i mean the money is a part of it
obviously but
uh it's more behavioral yeah it's where
you keep scores off yeah wow
absolutely powerful good stuff okay who
were your biggest cheerleaders uh my
friend john who gave me your book my
other friend lance and my other friend
co
the three of them all together
you know there were times where i was
like you know
i want to go on vacation i want to do
this and you know especially out last
year they're like nope wrap up that
mortgage you're so close just just just
finish it out the accountability the
encouragement you got to have it you got
to have cheerleaders in your corner man
100 they bring out the best for all of
our lives for any part of our life we
need that but you need it as you're
walking this debt-free journey for sure
correct and you've obviously done it in
the 12-step process too so pretty pretty
incredible thank you
thank you for your help and i mean that
well thank you thank you we're honored
to be again that's the best kind of
story to be a be a part of yes very very
cool all right so what was the hardest
part
uh
the hardest part was seeing all my
friends on vacation
they looked like they're having a good
time but uh they were yeah well
you know and and
really you know people do show up and
they try to do math for you
you know and just being able like have
thick skin and say uh you know what man
i think i'm gonna go ahead and take care
of
you know this interest maybe more and i
think i'm gonna follow this program i'm
not gonna follow your program yeah i
mean this guy seems to know he's talking
about so i'm gonna go ahead and do what
he's doing
[Laughter]
it's it's so powerful it brings to mind
an old phrase i heard one time from an
old preacher he said don't sacrifice the
future on the altar of the immediate
cool and you really model that you know
friends are going come on man come on
trying to give you their math and you're
like
no i could just see it all over you oh
yeah well they were doing it out of love
they weren't trying to set me up for
failure oh sure sure yeah yeah wow
that's powerful well done brother thank
you thank you all right let's bring your
daughter up what is her age uh this is
macy she's 19. all right very very cool
good stuff good stuff all right adam and
macy from cincinnati 226
000
paid off in two and a half years making
25 to 250. we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you and a copy of total
money makeover for you that's definitely
the uh maybe six millionaires definitely
the next chapter in your story you're
going to be on your way you'll be there
shortly this kind of money and no no
payments in the world wow way to go all
right adam and macy count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
it's amazing how much career
and how much
mental health
and
behavior decisions
all play into this whole thing of
building wealth yes
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at eight eight two
five five two two five sydney's with us
in baton rouge hi cindy welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave thank you so much for having me
sure what's up
um i was curious how you felt about um
or what the role of rebalancing your
accounts would be in your investments
for retirement
for example um like if we invest into
the four categories and one of them over
performs into 30 and 40 percent of our
overall portfolio at some point should
we rebalance that to get back down to 25
into all four categories or should we
just reevaluate the funds that we have
it won't hurt to rebalance them um it uh
the thing i don't wouldn't fool with is
there's not enough benefit to do it as
an obsession
i mean i know people i know people that
spend you know spend their entire
december rebalancing every year and
that's i wouldn't do that um it would
for my funds to get rebalanced they
would have to get completely out of
control to where i look up and i got 60
and one of the four
or something like that and i i probably
wouldn't want that
um
but uh
so far i've not had that issue
but if you end up that way but if you
get it to the point that it's making you
nervous that you're
you're you're not well diversified
anymore because you're too so heavy in
one category of the four then yeah you
probably would want to do that but that
might be
three times in your life
okay i was curious my employer offers it
as an automatic thing that could go in
quarterly or annually or every five
years however i would want to set it i
wouldn't
i would just
five years i could look at it you know
if you want to but um if it doesn't
automatically
they have the option to set that to
rebalance automatically yes sir okay i
mean if you said i'd say that five years
then
but
any sooner than that there's not a huge
benefit mathematically to the process
the big benefit is is that you don't get
too many of your eggs in one basket
you're not well diversified
if you're too heavy in one category that
so the benefit is just safety
you know you're not going to end up with
like
5 million extra money because you did
this it's not going to work out that way
but you mean you may end up with some
extra money but it's not going to be to
where you went oh the secret to me
having three million dollars is
rebalancing no you're not this is a
phrase no one has ever said
so because it's not possible
so
but it's a good question and i i did not
know they offered that as an automatic
thing that's cool i might want to look
into that for our team because i have
people ask me about it internally so i
was going to ask you so what is what was
going through that company's minds
they're obviously doing that as a
benefit are they looking at okay not
performing as well here so we're going
to move it around i mean well i mean if
you've got a if you've got a
balanced portfolio and it gets out of
balance you know sure that's a great
concern to some people emotionally
um and so it's probably not the company
it's probably the mutual fund company
that's servicing their 401k that just
thought oh that'd be a neat thing yeah
because those of us that are nerds are
concerned about that kind of thing uh
sydney's a wonderful nerd like me i mean
she's concerned about that it's a good
thing i mean non-nerds don't ask these
questions okay but this is still it's
it's a little good question even for you
non-nurses to hear the answer to yes it
is but um yeah that's uh uh
yeah it's
you know it it's you know
you can do you'd be more
i i would pay more attention to the
performance of the funds in my four
categories
overall than i would whether or not they
were balanced that's that's that's how i
tend to do it that's one i might move
over right i might actually make a move
if i've got a fund that is consistently
underperforming all the other funds in
its category exactly yeah then yeah i'm
going to probably make a move out of
that puppy ken is with us in sacramento
hi ken welcome to the ramsey show
thank you for taking my call kenneth
dave how are you today better than we
deserve what's up hey
we're very blessed and highly favored
i have a question we've been following
the program for years we're in a pretty
good financial spot at this point we're
looking to retire and move out of
california and uh
what is a good percentage looking at our
net worth that we should spend on our
retirement health
wow congratulations well done well thank
you the eyes have a lot to do with it
the data that we have says that
percentage changes the more your net
worth is
so what's your net worth
uh we're probably at 1.7 conservatives
good for you with the house
thank you the typical millionaire in
your range is going to be um
30 to 40 percent
okay that's the typical
no that's not to say you're going to go
broke if you go to 50 percent
but when you have north of 50 of your
1.7 million net worth that is not
generating an income
it's sitting in a house
because we're paying cash for the house
obviously we're having a dave ramsey
discussion right so
it's not generating an income so every
one of those dollars we put in that
house you're sidelining
it to create an income for the rest of
your lifestyle
that's why you don't want to get up you
know when you get up north of 50 it
starts to be an ouch on that
uh so but the typical millionaire we
studied in the millionaire study that we
did uh 1.7 we would often hear the house
was
uh four to seven hundred thousand
okay
you know that kind of thing
because we're gonna
yeah we're gonna go looking we really
want to see what's gonna be what are you
thinking about going
well y'all we've been practicing here
also we're thinking about uh south uh
western tennessee around lawrenceburg or
maybe down the lawrence killian alabama
area
okay well half a million dollars will
buy a stinking big house there
okay we just want something comfortable
and nice and uh oh i mean you're coming
from sacramento your mind's gonna be
blind
certainly it's southwest because what
you're talking about is that rural
tennessee and you know this is not
nashville prices you know nashville
prices are
considerably different or williamson
county that we live in which is adjacent
to nashville very expensive but
louisburg man bang for your buck's huge
it's a great little town too by the way
good people good beautiful out there
yeah oh it's pretty country really
pretty morgan is in good retirement yeah
morgan is in toledo hi morgan welcome to
the ramsay show
hi can i dave thanks for taking my call
sure um so i was just notified that our
health insurance premiums at my work are
increasing almost 40 it's going from 520
a month to 800 a month
basically my
my take-home pay is in effect dropping
13 so i take home about 2k a month it's
going down to 1700 a month
my question is it's like i want to ask
for a raise even though i just received
my
annual raise in october at my annual
review of four percent
but how do i ask for another raise but
also freeze it and i i'm not really
looking for a raise i just want to keep
my benefits my salary the same
because i don't really feel like i did
anything to deserve
such a hit in my salary
obamacare we've been fighting it around
here for about 10 years at our place
yeah this is a little different here
dave than in that she just came through
annual review but this is i'm guessing
across the board in the company but you
make 24 000 a year yeah
yeah my growth is 38k and i bring home
about 27 net because it's about in san
diego california what do you do oh no
this is this is oh i'm sorry toledo ohio
wrong call i'm sorry i got the wrong
thing that's okay
i can't read it
so what do you do okay
uh i'm a remote worker i work on
spreadsheets and like data analyzing
you have a degree
no i don't i started off as an executive
assistant and i just sort of morphed
into this so how old are you
uh 30. okay
yeah i think this is across the board
the company's made this decision so it
doesn't really put you in a position
where you can go hey you just you just
decreased one benefit if you will in the
sense that it's more money to you i
think you're looking elsewhere i don't
think that you're gonna have any kind of
short-term recourse to get this bump
that's what they're doing anyway they've
already made a financial decision and it
is negatively impacting you but they're
not going to just give you a bump it
doesn't sound like to me this is
company-wide so i'd be looking elsewhere
i think you have a lot greater
opportunity and to be honest with you i
think you can make a whole lot more
money elsewhere yeah i don't think
you're making any money that's why i was
asking all these questions yeah i want
you to make more money well the truth
the truth is i this job we call it a
unicorn job because it's remote
it's salary i can work on my own
schedule so i'm at like a stay-at-home
mom well you got to decide what the
trade-off is what do you want more let's
stay at home
okay
yeah i mean
yeah something's gonna give
but you're not making any money there's
nothing here this is not a job you dance
jump up and dance for there's just not
that much to it you go get another one
i'm with ken
[Music]
this is james childs a producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality host of the ken
coleman show number one best-selling
author
of the book paycheck to purpose is my
co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
work your career your relationships your
mental health and your money it all
works together you can't keep it from
doing it open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five nicole
is with us in san diego hi nicole
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
so my mother recently passed away in
november of last year and she left me
or named me as a beneficiary on her 401k
plan she had with her job
um
and i'm just trying to figure out kind
of what to do with it
okay how much is in it
so there's about 235 000
um both uh my husband and i were
debt-free our cars are paid for um our
husband's military so we don't own a
home but he will be retiring in about
three years so we want to kind of make
the best choice for our family um moving
forward whether it be investing or
saving for a house and just kind of
figuring out
how to really
use this money for a big purpose got it
okay cool all right i if i were in your
shoes i would go to ramseysolutions.com
and click on smart vester
which will connect you with one of the
smart vester pros that we recommend
we're not in the investment business but
one of these ladies or gentlemen will
sit down with you with the heart of a
teacher and tell you what some of your
options are
okay okay and um what i think will
happen is and probably what's wise is
you're going to roll this to an
inherited ira
account because it is an inherited
retirement account
and i would put it in good growth stock
mutual funds you'll probably end up
using it to buy a house later thank you
for your service tell your husband thank
you for his service
and um
the inherited ira
which you cannot avoid because this is
an inherited retirement account has a
mandatory withdrawal over 10 years
you're gonna have to take out a tenth of
it a year
okay
and uh that's new rules they put in
place because the government doesn't
want you to inherit it and leave it
alone they want their freaking tax money
and so they're going to force you to
liquidate it over the next 10 years
anyway
but you may liquidate it sooner than
that and just pay the taxes on it when
you do to have the money for the house
okay yes i do remember her mentoring the
ten year rule uh when i kind of called
to get an idea about it and she did that
we would have to withdraw a little bit
more than just the minimum in order to
make sure it was gone within that that
10-year period yeah but i i'm not
leaving it with the 401k i'm going to
roll it to an ira with a smart vester
pro where you have a person in your
corner that's advising you teaching you
showing you what your options are
and um we're not going to stay with your
mom's old company that's not a plan and
by the way for the rest of you when any
time you leave a job
you take your 401k with you always by
rolling it over to an ira because you
have control you have more options and
you have people that'll help you pay
better attention to it than the old
hr group at the old place always take it
with you it's portable
and that's one of the beauties
of the 401k plan
and ken what we're seeing um
from an employment perspective
when i started doing this show 30 years
ago a lot of companies the vast majority
companies had pensions
and a few of them had 401ks the 401k was
just starting to be a thing the ira was
starting to become a thing
and uh people like me pushed it hard
because it be because it's in your
control
a pension's not in your control
nowadays uh just a very small percentage
of companies have pensions and the vast
majority have 401ks and oh by the way 80
something percent of the companies have
a match
on the 401k but they do not have to fund
a pension
yeah i think the pension is just a thing
of the past i think that you know for a
variety of reasons you understand the
nuances of that better than i do but i
definitely think the 401ks are winning
um a winning program for people and thus
it's a winning program for companies and
so it's certainly with where everything
is right now
20 million people have changed jobs in
the last five months
salaries are going up
signing bonuses all kinds of benefits
companies are trying to do everything
they can to attract and retain talent
and obviously a 401k this is a benefit
that people now honestly expect they
really do expect it
you'll hear it if you don't have a good
program they won't join you yeah
kate and aaron are with us in dublin
ohio hi kate aaron how are you guys
hi dave we're doing well good what's up
thank you thank you so much for taking
our call uh so my brief story i'm a
worship pastor here in ohio i worked at
a church for almost 10 years and then
they began to embrace some
woke resources and ideology so i knew it
was time to move on
um the next solid option that god opened
the doors for were me to come down here
to columbus to raise a family at a
different church but we're feeling
pretty discouraged um
the same house
that
uh lived in back home from where we were
up northeast is a hundred thousand
dollars more in this area
we're currently staying in a percentage
rent free with no utilities
we paid off our home before we moved
down here
but we don't want to purchase a home
that is already
we're already outgrowing with the
current state of our family
after yeah they're just paying off our
house for this so we're essentially we'd
have to get a mortgage for
a minimum a hundred thousand dollars
probably more because of how crazy the
market is here um for the same house we
just paid off how long can you stay in
the power stage
we negotiated yeah we negotiated three
more months uh when i signed and and
took on with this job so three months
from today um but i'm sure they would
allow us to stay here a little longer
they're pretty flexible
um i think our concern with that and
same breath is can we save quickly
enough um as we've noticed like the mark
the market is just that one that wasn't
why i was asking
got it the reason i was asking was to
give you time to calm down
yeah because you're pretty hyped up
yeah we're exhausted
i can hear it man i mean you're like ah
you're around that you're on your last
nerve man
and worship pastors are known for
getting rich i mean they just you guys
make so much money yeah right yeah right
not at all
youth pastors worship pastors as a
christian version of starving people to
death but yeah
we love you we followed your principles
when we first got married we paid off
all our debt we paid up our mortgage
we've been um investing a little um we
just don't want to destroy all of that
progress i appreciate that would this be
the next option we have we just had
another baby what is your household
income
now sixty-five thousand okay plus dan
and uh kate are you working outside the
home with that or you got the babies
yeah no i was but after we had our
second weed shows i chose to stay home
don't blame you okay i'll tell you what
guys um i want to help you on this i and
i hear it in your voice
i'm not making fun of you i'm just i get
it i understand and been there so hang
on through this stupid commercial break
we'll go make some money so we can come
back and help you with your money okay
all right all right be right back this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
kate and aaron are in dublin ohio uh new
job is a worship pastor much more
expensive area than they came from
they're temporarily housed in the
parsonage but only for a few more months
and then they got to make a decision
okay staying at home with the new babies
aaron's making 65 and a little bit of a
shock to the system when they got to the
more expensive area is that a fair
summary of what you guys told us very
fair what'd you sell your house for in
the other place
205 okay and um you've been trying to
find something comparable closer to the
church reasonably close to the church
anyway and what price range are you
finding there there's something
comparable
well
you said you said 100 extra right so
about didn't you say i would say
yeah 315 320 would be a comparable
parallel move okay got it but asking
they're selling for far beyond that we
saw one house we were interested in go
for 50 000 above asking cash which is
just insane yeah yeah yeah
okay so um here's the thing
uh you're either going you're going to
do one of two or three things number one
i want you to figure out a way to slow
this process down
because when the more options you have
the more information you have the better
decision you're gonna make
this feels very urgent very forced
and i smell a bad decision coming
yeah
does that feel right to you like you're
stressed like you're against the wall
and you're you're backed up and you're
going to say something later like i was
forced to
you weren't really forced you just put
yourself in that corner
yeah okay so i want to slow down so that
might look like renting for a year
okay and just calm just breathe a little
and during that year number one we're
going to learn more about the area than
we know now
which will give you more options
um you're going to discover how far out
you have to drive for the prices to
start dropping
you know there's a point in which the
lines cross between ridiculous commute
and great price
yeah i've got a 15-minute commute so i'm
spoiled
um you know but if you went 15 minutes
further than my house the prices dropped
because i'm kind of on the edge of rule
where i am now
you know what i'm saying
and the further you get out in the
country the better the prices are right
right but you know but the but that you
know so you got to find that because you
don't want a two-hour commute
right yeah you know you but you do you
you do you probably are not going to be
in the back door of this church we
probably already figured that out or
you're going to
spend that year
uh piling up cash and trying to say
we're going to get a 50 000 mortgage and
not 100 000
and we're going to bite that bullet and
that's the price we're going to pay to
be there rather than in in place a
rather than place b
the other thing you're going to be able
to do when you do that is you can slow
down and you don't feel forced into one
of these crazy bidding wars
because you have to choose from what's
on the plate right now
you can say over the next year i'm going
to find something to sneak up on
okay i'll give you an example of what
happens when you slow down okay this
one's weird this one's weird but this
happened to a friend of mine not long
ago
medium middle middle class price range
house a little bit more than you all are
talking about but in our area it's a
little bit more okay
and uh we've got all these people moving
from other states to tennessee to the
point that to get away from the
craziness and to the point it's almost
like a joke like california
uh refugees in tennessee i mean it's
just it's like a running joke and for
the people moving here it is they're
laughing too but it's like californians
are buying everything you know inside
it's like you can't get a house because
stupid california is buying everything
it is this kind of thing's going on this
is the talk around the water cooler you
know i'm not mad at you people from
california this is what's really going
on so my friend actually you know and
the bidding wars are big time in
nashville it's hard to get a house
big time
my friend actually found a guy who sold
her a house
at below market price right not much
below but just slightly below um so that
he didn't have to sell it to somebody
from california
yeah he was worried about voting
he's just like it was a personal thing
you know and and that you know and that
it's funny but you'll find something
where
god god will supply your needs
where there's somebody that says you
know what i might can put this house up
for a bidding war but i'm gonna bless
this young worship pastor and sell it to
him at
at appraisal instead of 50 over
appraisal
and you know you'll find that through
someone at the church word of mouth even
through the real estate agent that puts
the word out there that's what's going
on
and god is not shocked by where you are
he's not surprised
i would add here's what another year
allows you to do you could put the word
out in your actual church community you
don't know yet maybe you already know
that there's a couple contractors
people that could actually help you
renovate something to where you could
find a jewel
it's not a piece of trash or a death
trap but something that needs some tlc
get it cheaper but it has the square
footage that you need and it turns into
an unbelievable financial gain for you
down the line i mean those are
possibilities i'm not saying that's your
only option but that's something to
consider we're going to get something
like that you pay cash for what i want
more for you guys than anything is peace
that you don't have right now yeah
right right
and we need it you got little babies
you're you feel like you're a thousand
miles from home and you don't have
enough money and and it's just frenetic
and frantic and anxiety and um
and i don't blame you for being there
but i kind of heard all of that in your
way you were talking earlier
and i'm already hearing a tone change
just by telling you to wait a year i'm
hearing you calm down a little bit
that's true
what principles would you say about
renting and any wisdom on that um some
renting properties we've seen here
they're going for 2500 yeah as cheap as
possible because we're just buying time
whatever whatever money you spend on
rents buying time that's all it is and
the cheaper you can get
obviously the less you're paying for the
time and the more you can save towards
uh you can add to this pile of savings
you got from the sale of your other
house and so yeah that twenty five
hundred dollars doesn't sound very
appealing are there real space issues in
the parsonage
uh some
well not space just um
more of a i would say an updating and
space for the kids and safety yeah how
long will they let you i mean if you
could talk the minutes let you stay
there for nine months you know maybe
it's not maybe the magic number is not a
year and the beautiful thing about the
parsonage is you could leave at any time
without breaking a lease if you found
something
sure
they've been so kind and i'm sure they
would allow us to do that yeah i would
ask for and say listen here's what
here's the council i've been given the
council i've been given is to slow down
and gather more options and more
information and that feels right to us
we'd rather not move to a rental can
you know if you could suck it up and
live there for free and they'll let you
and still do this extended time a little
bit that's what definitely i would do
that yeah i if there's some safety
issues i'd ask the church to address the
safety issues the kids don't care about
the updating and you guys can put up
with them it's camping it's an adventure
it's a nine month adventure yeah
yeah it feels like camping for sure
i mean just look at it as you know hey
we're we're going to do this as an
adventure it's what we're going to you
know it's the same thing you you know
these people that sell their house and
live in an rv or something it's an
adventure we're going to do this and so
it's not it's certainly not doing it for
the luxury or something like that but um
and let the let the timing
unfold
uh i love swindoll's saying he says uh
god is never late but seldom early
mm-hmm yeah and so just just give
yourself a little bit of room and let
the holy spirit massage this situation
and you in the process and
and um i think this is going to turn out
okay a year from today
i really do
all of my life experience and my faith
experience points to the fact that it's
going to turn out okay but it's not
going to turn out okay if you feel
pressured
cornered
anxiety ridden
like you're forced into something
and um
you know then you'll go you'll look back
and you go and then god
gave us this house yeah yeah and i i've
done that with houses many times yeah
house i'm living in right now yeah i
feel like it was the same thing i had a
lot of options i
kept moving the options around until i
turned over the right shell and the p
was there you know
but lots of options and lots of
information gives you slow down gives
you better decisions
really good question you guys i'm proud
of you thank you for calling i hope that
helps
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're glad you're here in the
lobby of ramsey solutions on the debt
free stage jacob is with us hi jacob how
are you hey i'm doing great how are you
better than i deserve man welcome where
do you live i live in uh reading
california cool good to have you welcome
how much debt have you paid off paid off
63 000 in uh about two and a half years
good for you and your range of income
during that time so started off about 37
000 and currently 61 000. good for you
cool what kind of debt was the 63 oh man
all kinds of stupid
man so i had student loans i had uh
credit cards i had car loans i'm
normal yeah normal um
yeah and then all of a sudden stupid tax
with a 14 interest rate with wells fargo
student loan so whoa oh man oh it was
yeah yeah it was pricey what do you do
for a living i'm a social worker good
for you yeah good for you
so uh this is very cool man good for you
i'm proud of you how old are you i'm 29.
wow you killed it yeah so what happened
two and a half years ago what was the
wake-up call how did you get connected
to this ramsay stuff so
originally it started in 2017. i was a
youth pastor at a local church in red
bluff california which is 30 miles south
um and uh
one of uh the members of our church who
wanted to start uh financial peace
university he approached me asked me hey
what do you think of this you want to
join us i'm like i'm i don't have any
debt i'm 17 i have 70 000 in savings i'm
good i'll never have to worry about that
i'm kind of out of arrogant attitude
george
well
two years later um i felt like i needed
to resign went through the seventeen
thousand dollars of my emergency fund
um
i blinked and i had
nothing and i was living on my credit
card
um and
all of a sudden i had
thirty thousand dollars worth of student
loans i had
um a car that broke down that i had a
200
car payment and then that broke down so
i still had a little bit of debt that
had to go into a new car and so it
carried over
and yeah blinked and 63 000 in debt in
about five months and oh yeah yeah
that's what i said um
and then uh one day it was june of uh
2019 and um friends i hang out with on
friday night they were like yeah we're
doing this financial peace university
stuff i'm like i don't really want to do
that that doesn't sound fun
and
and then uh
but i had nobody to hang out with and so
oh there it is
this is my best marketing plan limited
social ability
so we all took it together and uh man i
i
uh got on the plan and i became addicted
uh to be quite honest the first budget
hurt um because i did not realize how
much i was spending um
and uh once uh about two and a half
months uh two and a half months later
i met my lovely fiance now and uh
um
and she wanted to go through fpu um you
can't get away from it i couldn't every
i really cut it so we went again uh in
february of 2020
um and with the same just in time for
the pandemic it was in the middle of
pandemic we went to this new thing
called uh
zoom we had no clue what it was at the
time now that's what we do but um yeah
so uh
we went through it she was debt free we
met in college uh she went through
college completely debt-free i admired
her for that because i had student loans
at the wazoo
and just started that journey yeah
very cool good for you thank you well
done when you're getting married
uh we don't have a date set um we're
thinking sometime between october and
january of this year and next year good
for you wow very good yeah thank you
very cool
so what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is you paid off 63
thousand dollars in uh two and a half
years
yeah um for me the key was vulnerability
um
so for me uh um when i was doing
everything in private it was easy to
like hide my wounds and hide the the
hurt that i had
and when
um i had true vulnerability and i was
like you know i don't know what i'm
talking about i don't know what i'm
doing i need help here's my wounds
here's here's my here's my 63 000 of
drowning
um i need help and that was the turning
point for me was when i was able to get
to that point of humility and
vulnerability of just reaching out for
help wow yeah yeah i want to ask you
this is really interesting so you go and
you take fpu so there you're with a
group of people how quickly did you go
from and i'm not sure you had real shame
but i think the vulnerability how did
you how soon did you go from negative
emotions about yourself to realizing
what it's like i'm not the only one and
i'm here with other people who are
admitting the same thing that
vulnerability how did that translate for
you as you kept going through it
you know you uh hit the nail on the head
uh shame is that uh two-headed monster
that
is real in our own
imagination yeah but when we go into
community
um it's like man like you're you're here
too um i think of c.s lewis's quote of
how friends are made it's like no way i
thought i was only one
so
um that was honestly the thing for me
was once i started hearing like wow
other people are on the same journey as
me um and the other part was just
admitting that you know
um
i'm not the smartest man in the room um
there's people out there who've been
there done that
um and already found ways to trailblaze
why why am i trying my own path and just
following those who came before me and
just following their path
i might be the smartest man in the room
but it would be about a very limited
subject
[Laughter]
yes yes
a subject of your choosing i might have
you you might you might say that
oh that's awesome you're awesome man
this is yeah that really is strong
there's something about that that um
you know god gave me the gift of going
broke and having the story to tell other
people that you know i've been there too
i know how it feels
and uh it's not a gift i want to give to
anybody but um
but but uh that drops you know it lowers
the shame because the guy teaching this
has been broke
and so it's not a glasses on the end of
your nose talking down to someone it's
i've been there too dude
and so that that makes a ton of
difference in that vulnerability um
uh i hadn't thought about it as a
precursor to transformation
but that's a that's a beautiful picture
it's a really pretty picture well done
well done good job well i'm proud of you
man you're a hero who are your biggest
cheerleaders financial peace university
people and the fiance yeah so phil and
jill mon um they're the coordinators
that were at my church um they were huge
because
they were broke in 2006 and then seven
years later they retired early and was
like wow i wouldn't be like you guys
like i don't know how you guys did it
um they were they were huge cheerleaders
uh my brother he went through it as well
um and he paid off a lot of debt as well
and uh he beat me by a month of being
debt-free so that was kind of the
the thing that we're going back and
forth and he beat me but
i'm here so i still won though that's
right yeah this is not a race you really
lose this is pretty powerful and then
also my fiance as well she was huge um
she's the nerd in the relationship and
i'm the free spirit and
i go out and do whatever i do and she's
like this is the plan though like we
kind of keep in mind keep in mind yeah
that's good
well done proud of you jacob good work
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story to go on and uh become a baby
steps millionaire be outrageously
generous live like no one else so later
you can live and give like no one else a
copy of total money makeover for you to
give away there's probably someone
that's gotten like six copies of that
book and you're going to be the seventh
and that gets them to do it finally ends
up being a coaster on some people's
table but it's all right it's a good
book so check it out and we thank you
for coming by man very well done jacob
from reading california 63 000 paid off
in two and a half years making 37 to 61.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three
two
one i'm debt free
this is how it's done
yeah baby
love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you're married imagine never having
another money argument
it's the number one thing married
couples fight about this money stuff
so how much better would your marriage
be what about your whole family like
happy valentine's day hello when you get
on the same page with money you have
more peace in your finances and in your
relationship
and here's the best way to do it join a
financial peace university class you'll
learn how to make a budget together
and follow our proven money plan so you
can not only stop fighting about money
you can start chasing your goals and you
do it as a team the probability of you
getting out of debt and becoming wealthy
goes way up
millions of couples have gone through
this class and say it's the best thing
they could have done for their marriage
financial peace university it can be for
you to decide today that you're ready
and get on the same page well just join
a financial peace university class you
can get started with a free trial visit
ramseysolutions.com
fpu ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu sean is with us in colorado springs
hey sean welcome to the ramsey show
thank you for taking my call dave how
are you doing better than i deserve
what's up
so don and dirty been my life uh for a
long time has been on baby step seven
and truly baby step seven good for you
and
and we have our six month emergency fund
we set off of how much we know we can
live off of in a year
we have saved up a lot of money just
recently came back from deployment we
saved that substantial amount of money
that this is sitting there but we fully
fund our rock tsp rock iras 401ks esa we
have one vsa left that we can still
contribute to so the question is i have
an old dave ramsey beater truck
and everybody keeps telling me hey man
you're doing so well why don't you
upgrade
my argument for this is
i know i'm nearing retirement the wife
will still work i'll be in the time and
i still gotta wait on that um
government pension to kick in
and so i don't know how much money i
need to save you know for that any kind
of contingencies that come up or if i'm
just being too stinky with myself and i
get to live a little bit and upgrade i
i'm we are worth and we are millionaire
next door to millionaires
so your you know your policy is worth a
million dollars or more cash for the
vehicle do it
but i got other things coming up like i
said retirement do i upgrade or do i
just hold off
how expensive a truck are you talking
about buying
i i don't think i can ever just out now
buy a brand new vehicle especially right
now either twice as much as they used to
be
let's pretend that you did
what was how expensive a truck would
that be what would you spend
60 000
and you have a net worth of what
uh 1.2 million and a household income of
what
approximately 100 to 120 000 a year okay
the way i make decisions on things like
this
is i ask myself because this is just a
it's just a luxury item
okay it's just something fun to buy
it's all it is right
necessarily
it doesn't have to be the truck is a
want
but it's it's it's
a toy they're wanting to buy and and
that's how you're that's why you're
holding off emotionally
if you take sixty thousand dollars cash
in 100 bills uncle benjamin franklin
and you put it in the fireplace and lit
it on fire and watched it burn
your life does not change one ounce
okay
you've got
1.4 million dollars 1.3 million dollars
minus 60 000 you're gonna be you make a
hundred and some thousand dollars a year
you're gonna be just fine if you burned
it
just to watch it go up the chimney now
i'm obviously not suggesting that that's
ludicrous
okay
but um buying a truck that goes down in
value is fairly close to that but it's
not the same thing and so what would i
do if i woke up in your shoes
um
i wouldn't
be rash and i wouldn't be out of control
but sometime in the next six months i
would be the owner of a new pickup truck
i think you should
this is that's what i call your advice
he's processing you can hear it
you can hear the grier the gear is
grinding there buddy
do you hear what i'm saying that it's
not you're not making an unwise decision
that's the point of my metaphor
yes
you're fine you've done a great job
you scored
touchdown that was my wife she she made
she made me do it so i think her every
day well that's fine you and your wife
you're smart together you're smart i
mean you're just you're you just did
great touchdown
touchdown you just scored a freaking
touchdown now do the touchdown dance buy
the truck
enjoy something we're not being rash i'm
not suggesting you spend a million of
your million for
if six hundred thousand sixty thousand
dollars ain't spit
because you've done such a good job
and this is the beauty of living like no
one else so that later you can live
and to give
like no one else i also want you to be
on a steady diet of generosity
that's important
you will get more enjoyment with of the
things that you actually own if you're
also simultaneously generous
it somehow gives you permission to enjoy
the nice things
that's absolutely right and i got to
tell you you know this is amateur
psychology advice here but i would go
just do some test drives just ease into
this because he's got this you know he's
just he's been gazelle intense they've
done it the right way
and he's still going okay what about the
pension and you're thinking and the
reality is everything you and your wife
have done as a team together to walk the
baby steps
you're not gonna do something stupid the
very source of this question means you
are not going to do stupid with money
he's won that battle allow yourself to
celebrate as dave saying but not just
with the truck but to go wait a second
we did this
we're going to be not just fine
we are millionaires and we're going to
be wise and i i go test drive a couple
and just ease into it psychologically
then i think it feels a little better if
you have that money invested decently
1.2 million will be 2.4 in seven years
exactly if you don't add anything to it
that's correct right so that that you
know you you're gonna be okay man yeah
you've done great you're gonna be all
right it's gonna work out it's gonna
work out this is why we teach this stuff
this is truly a baby steps millionaire
yeah you know truly what the you know
the reason i guess one of the reasons
the book's the number one bestseller
yeah but um well i've asked you about
this before on the air and i think i
think it's good to do it again there is
this is a normal psychological response
for somebody that was cheetah you know
like gazelle intense you know you know
get away from the cheetah go after it
you know and it's hard to adjust to it
yeah
it's hard to spend money on something
like that when you've been so
disciplined yeah and it's a lot harder
for those folks for those of us that
earned it
the old-fashioned way we earned it you
know that thing that old commercial
right better believe it it's a lot
harder for us to let loose and enjoy the
money that is someone that gets sudden
wealth that's true sudden wealth that's
one of the reasons the bible talks about
it being dangerous
is you you um
it can come sudden and somehow you don't
have that trepidation
about spending something you know that's
why a lot of winners uh end up broke
more often than they do wealthy yeah
there are no emotional calluses to
remember
yeah the bankruptcy rate is four times
the national average among
uh you're four times more likely to file
bankruptcy if you uh got won the lotto
than if you didn't
that's that's pretty bizarre that is
crazy the divorce rate is six times the
national average among a lot of owners
so it's like um
couldn't afford to get rid of her before
i don't know what is the deal man how
does that work it's a great point though
if you think about it where where did
why
why does the divorce go up yeah back
when it was hard and you know it doesn't
make sense but i guess you know we
always laughed and said sharon didn't
leave when we went broke because she
didn't have a car but i mean that was uh
uh you know that was somewhat of a
laughing thing and somewhat true so
maybe there's something to it right oh
yeah but we know she really loves you
now because you know it's valentine's
day she has to it's like federal that is
true it's federal law that is true so if
you've been married 40 years it's
federal law you have to love your
husband on valentine's day
even if he's dave ramsey you still have
to love him
i was not aware of this legislation
little known piece of uh it's a sub sub
category the roth ira they buried it the
budget they buried it in the budget
where they bury everything that's right
where great things go to die
oh my gosh
ken coleman ramsey personality my
co-host good hour good job to the folks
in the booth the booth people they did a
great job
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we talk about your career your work
your mental health your relationships
your boundaries and your money it all
shows up right here on the ramsey show
thank you for joining us triple eight
eight two five five two two five gavin
is with us in minnesota hi gavin welcome
to the ramsey show
thank you very much guys how are you
today better than we deserve brother how
can we help
so my wife and i currently
live in a 600 square foot apartment
we are seventeen thousand dollars in
debt uh with a truck that um my i had to
get for my job and we have an
opportunity to rent to own
five acres with a 900 square foot cabin
on it that needs about five grand of
improvements to make it livable and i'm
not entirely sure what course of action
to take
while i'm trying to do the baby steps in
this situation
you don't have the money
correct well we have five thousand
dollars saved up um in addition to our
emergency fund of a thousand dollars
without um and that's not including
retirement
but that saving is in mutual funds and
bleed we're not entirely sure if we
should just be patient wait for another
opportunity in the next few years and
allow that savings to
keep growing or
because we're on baby step two cancel
all of that um extra investing into
mutual funds and then
take out that money to make the
improvements and then
do 500 a month on a rent to own rather
than renting a property that we're only
temporarily
living in
[Music]
um gavin how old are you guys
i am 20 and my wife is 21.
[Music]
okay
um
well let's walk through a couple of
things here um one is i want to go back
and revisit the statement your work
requires you to go into debt to buy them
a truck
i'm so confident that is correct
i'm so confused
what's your husband
my wife works part-time and she brings
in about six hundred dollars a month and
then i bring in about twenty four
hundred dollars a month why does she
work part-time
well she applied for a full-time
position but she's only getting
part-time hours right now and she is
pregnant so she doesn't want to
start a full-time position right before
going on maternity leave that that
matters okay that that's good
information all right now
um and you make
thirty thousand dollars a year and you
have a seventeen thousand dollar truck
correct yeah okay
well it was twenty four thousand but
then we've been attacking it so now it's
down to seventeen but yeah but it's
insanity
so why do they require you to buy a
truck why don't they furnish you a truck
um that would be that is a great
question i have to like i put on 5 000
miles a month um supervising 13
different hog barns and they require me
to have a decent vehicle they do pay me
mileage so they they do pay
for the insurance with that pension they
pay for the insurance and the
minimum payment however all that debt is
still in my name not theirs
okay you don't get paid enough
for them to do this to you
and you to accept it
your deal
sucks
60 000 miles a year on a pickup truck
you know what you're doing to the value
of that pickup truck you're destroying
down down down yeah you're destroying
the value of that pickup truck
and so you're you're actually probably
paying them to work there when all the
smoke clears on this
just because the value of the truck
decreases so rapidly i mean when you
lose when you make thirty thousand
dollars a year and you lose ten thousand
dollars for the opportunity
that doesn't work dude yeah i have a
quick question on the they require you
to have a decent vehicle what does that
mean that fuel means they want him to be
able to get to 13 different hog barns
yeah without breaking right they want me
to put on that many miles a year without
it breaking down on me and be
they uh because of biosecurity reasons
just because there's so many um hogs so
i don't spread diseases as a bee
and i have to transport some other
individuals so it has to be a crew cab
it has to be a leather seat so it can be
disinfected um on a regular basis
i was gonna say because i was gonna come
at the i can get you a much more
affordable truck that'll get you to all
those hog farms but that's a whole
nother deal yeah this is right they're
ripping them off
your employer are completely asinine
this is ridiculous
that they require all of this for you
and you work your butt off for the no
more money than you're making
i mean they really got
some nerve
um so are you in a a very ru extremely
rural area
uh yes yeah okay
all right
i would say 80 of miles are on um are on
the interstate doesn't matter
but
is this a long term play for you do you
want to be in this particular industry
and this is a really good rung on the
ladder to get you where you want to go
this is not my dream job and i do not
want to have this job until i retire if
that answers your question
what is your dream job
my dream job is to be able to uh
to really farm full-time but that's not
attainable anywhere in the near future
right so my question is is this job
right now besides the fact you're
getting ripped off is it strategic for
you you feel like this is the rung on
the ladder i need to be on to keep
climbing towards farming or no
um to have the amount of income that i
do i doubled my income when i moved to
this job
so and right now i don't seem to have
any other opportunities super close to
home in order to maintain that income
within ten thousand dollars both ways
a year
um without
without driving an hour and a half to
two hours to work
wow
how open to
moving outside of this area are you and
your
uh wife
not very just let me stop let me just
stop you for a second with what they're
costing you by requiring this truck you
guys are living below the poverty level
that's why we're so concerned yeah
you're you're not making any money
you you're livi it's a moral it's a
mathematical mirage because you're
destroying 25 dollars while you're
making thirty thousand
and um the this requirement uh that
they've got on a 21 year old young man
and at least you've accepted it as a
requirement it's not it's just
unreasonable
and so they either need to furnish you a
truck or you need to look for a job
somewhere else and that may mean a move
it may mean uprooting your family but
no you don't need to buy this cabin
you're broke and in debt and your career
sucks
so you've got to get some of those
things fixed first before you start
talking about doing a rent to own on a
fixer-upper cabin
so um
um i think you got to solve your job
situation in this truck situation
because this truck just needs to go
bye-bye and if that means the job goes
bye-bye you need to have something lined
up hold on i'm going to have ken send
you a copy of have the team send you a
copy of ken's book paycheck to purpose
because
you know you called about the cabin but
the cabin's not your issue no you don't
buy the cabin
yes you've got to get rid of this truck
and that may mean you need to change
jobs
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today over the last 30 years
i've talked with tens of thousands of
people and their families to help them
overcome their financial stress we found
that money stress is one of all the
kinds of ways we experience stress
people struggle with stress anxiety
loneliness all at the same time
here's the good news dr john dolone has
a new book called own your past change
your future
where he will walk you through a
not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
with personal stories and decades of
experience and research dr daloni shows
us how to transform hurt
into healing
move from hopelessness to hopefulness
and the book is available for pre-order
right now
own your past change your future we'll
show you how to deal with all kinds of
trauma
how to get connected to a community and
make friends as an adult
and the steps you can take to change
your thoughts and your actions it is
possible write a news story
and here's why you should pre-order
right now
the book will come out in april and
we're in pre-sale right now but if you
pre-order you're going to get free bonus
items that include an entire month
of free
one-on-one therapy with our friends at
betterhelp
so pre-order pre-order your own copy of
own your past change your future it's
only twenty dollars
you get everything in the world with it
including this
month of help from
better
all at
ramseysolutions.com the book is own your
past change your future dr john delony
hot hot topic right now in this world
that we live in full of
lots of hurt out there steve's with us
in montgomery alabama hi steve welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave uh thank you so much for taking
my call
i've been listening to you for so many
years and i finally hit rock bottom
and i need your help okay
i'm i've been in the army now for 20
years
and i'm going to be retiring in two
years
and my family and i are in chapter 13
bankruptcy
when we were in washington state uh we
were full-time rv years
and we fell into buying a brand new
fifth wheel that was a hundred thousand
dollars and it ended up being a lemon
and because we're military and have
you know alabama driver's license oregon
plates bought it in washington etc etc
a lawyer told me that lemon law wouldn't
work and our best thing was chapter 13.
so we're uh 21 months into our chapter
13
and we have
32 000 left in the bankruptcy
i have now you surrender the trailer
yes we surrendered it okay but uh they
missed the deadline
so they didn't get any money
so you surrendered the trailer and
there's no
um
they missed the deadline to file under
the chapter 13.
that's correct and for any for any uh
deficit on the repossession i see
that's correct yes
all right so the 32 000 that's in the
chapter 13 is what
it's my wife's car
and my truck
and then four credit cards what do you
owe on the car in the truck
uh on the car is 18
on my truck is nine
and then on each of the credit cards is
four
four five five thousand dollars is not
vehicles the rest of it's all vehicles
that's correct so what's your household
income
so
gross is 90 000.
you know i'm active duty army and
everything and
and i have
you know i have i've just been horrible
with money i'm going to be perfectly
honest with you
i've been a multi-tour deployments
and you know money's huge while you're
deployed spend spend spend spend and
i've realized my mistakes
i'm sick and tired of living paycheck to
paycheck and just wondering where's the
money at
well thank you thank you thank you for
your service
and uh yes i appreciate that you're
appreciate you're ready to turn this
around
so yes sir
what you could do
is um do you have any money saved now
that you've been in this for 22 months
uh nothing at all okay
all right
i would run a kelly blue book on both of
these cars and see what in this
ridiculous car market what they're
selling for
it's possible you could sell them for
enough to get out of them
okay
and if you did that
um you could voluntarily dismiss the 13.
you would only have 5 000 in debt left
making 90 000 now we quickly got to get
you a couple beater cars that you pay
cash for to drive around to get this
behind you but if you had two beater
cars that you paid a couple thousand
bucks each for right quick
you um
release this um
you you sell these cars yes sir and then
you you know dive in dive on the credit
cards and get them paid off
i think you're free and you're
completely debt-free and you're ready to
start your life fresh and you're out of
the bankruptcy yes sir
but if the car the car the cars would
have to sell for enough to get you out
of them
right okay
they might sell for more
yeah they probably would down here in
this market because
what are the cars real quick while
you're talking to dave i want to do some
research
yeah so the
the truck
is a 2009 dodge ram 3500 that was used
to pull
the fifth wheel okay what's the car
and the car is a 2016 toyota rav4
um
it's the it's pretty high up on the
options list yeah well i'm gonna i'm
gonna guess i'm gonna go even further
now
i'm gonna guess that when you look these
things up you can sell them for enough
to completely pay off all of your debt
and have a little money in your pocket
i'll bet you they bring more than five
thousand dollars total than you owe
and then we got to get you a couple of
little dinky butt cars of some kind to
get around in for just a little while
but if you make 90 000 and you're on a
ramsay budget and we show you how to
handle money in financial peace
university and you don't have a payment
in the world
you're going to be just fine
you're going to quickly be able to get
better cars and pay cash for them
yes sir and that's that's what i want to
get to would you all would you and your
wife sacrifice these cars
i know that i would and i can i believe
i could
justify it to her because she's
she's
her entire
she's taking on the entire role of
making the family function financially
and she does the lion's share and i
wonder how in the world she does it and
she's tired um okay and she's so nice
here's what we're gonna do there's one
last thing you've got to do that i do
not know the answer to
and you you hear me clearly you have to
get the answer to this question
if you step out of this bankruptcy with
a voluntary dismissal can the old fifth
wheel company come after you for the
deficit then are you stepping out from
under the shield of bankruptcy i'm not
sure if they can or not
if they could come after you for 40 000
bucks because we suggest you file
early voluntary dismissal on this
bankruptcy then you're not gonna do that
okay okay so you got to make sure they
don't come around take your head off
after we take you out of this because
basically you have a force f force field
around you called bankruptcy protecting
you
yes sir okay and if you let that force
field down we don't want the fifth wheel
people to shoot at you okay
yes sir so i should i should talk to my
lawyer and talk to your lawyer and find
out if you file if you vo if you sell
the cars and voluntarily dismiss and get
out of the bankruptcy and clear up all
your debt
does that leave the fifth wheel people
open to come after you
i don't know the answer to that question
i think it might
and that's what's scaring me
so uh what'd you find ken that uh you
got a 2016 toyota rav4 anywhere from 103
000 miles for 20 00 990 or
one with 88 000 miles 24 990. i went a
little on the higher amount you get the
uh
i didn't get i didn't get the ram the
2000 more than it's
you're absolutely right they can clear
their bankruptcy completely by selling
these two cars and go get you a couple
of beaters that's exactly what i do but
not if they're gonna do this now hang on
kelly's gonna sign you guys up for
financial peace university you and your
wife as our gift to say thank you for
your service and it's time for you to
change your life steve
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage tobin and lindsay are
from us are with us from atlanta
actually a little south of atlanta right
that's right welcome guys good to have
you guys it's so good to have you
welcome how much debt have you paid off
we paid off a hundred and eight thousand
dollars all right how long did that take
30 months wow and your range of income
during that time
150 to 220. good for you what do you
guys do for a living
automotive finance ah both of you
mm-hmm both of you are working the same
thing
okay cool very cool at a local dealer or
what for a bank for a bank okay yes all
right cool very good well welcome guys
what kind of debt was the 108 000
it was a little bit of everything
um
cars motorcycles
credit cards student loans
average what was the sounds kind of
normal what was the most expensive
motorcycle
oh man that one hurt
that was a 2013 harley soft tail classic
and uh i think 15 grand we owed on it
yeah it hurt because you liked it oh
yeah i brought it for him for his
birthday
i did i did so i had a call she's
calling off respect
you can see that far and away look when
she talked about it you still remember
the pain of that one i do that thing
driving oil i may have cried a little
tear when it drove away yeah might have
happened yeah okay so what flipped you
guys what in the world made you two and
a half years ago decide to go crazy and
do ramsey
well
so we went to a financial fpu class at
our local church
and
that was it we went into it like
personally we had separate bank accounts
we were doing our own thing and me i'll
just i'll just go ahead and air my dirty
laundry i went in like this sure i'm
good sure i know about money sure i mean
freaking fine yeah that's just what i do
for a living yeah i mean i got it no
problem yeah
that's right i don't think he said
anything for the first three classes
actual body language was this yeah yeah
i don't want to be here she drugged me
yeah all right
cool then what happened how how what
unfolded the arms
just
submitting to the process just going why
would you do that
i mean what happened because they have
one in front of the
that got you to go oh wait
well
so for you like you you really
just going through the whole thing and
actually the statement was this that
sticks with me is you said and you were
more elegant was i can't live in the
apartment
that's ran by a 20-something-year-old
kid in another state
but i can buy the entire
complex
i think it was at that time you realized
like the money
thing that we've all always thought
about just didn't make sense it was
trying to do a different approach yeah
it was just changing our behavior yeah
okay but you had to believe that there's
a different way of measuring winning
absolutely and you say okay the fico is
not the measure
it's a great fico worshiping at the
altar of the great fico that's what that
little riff is about yeah i don't have a
fico score so i can't run an apartment
if they require that that's what that
whole reference yeah
and so yeah oh my gosh that's wild good
for you guys how long y'all been married
six years okay so two and a half of the
six you've been on this journey yes
all right very cool
and um now you're completely dead free
everything but the house everything but
the house we have that slated to be pay
off in two years wow look at you
wow so how does it feel now
feels great um it's nice to be able to
just pay cash for things
um
you know to tell you the truth i always
say we weren't really gazelle intense we
were more like hippopotamus intense
because we were we were still going on
vacations and going out to eat and that
sort of thing we just did a little bit
slower on purpose we probably could have
done it in about 24 months yeah i was
looking at your income yeah you could
have done a lot better yeah yes that's
right
i wasn't going to call you out on your
debt free scream day but there you go
yeah that's good
good very good that's okay you got out
we did will you go back
oh no no
no
no sir no way i'm not gonna talk you
into it huh no okay
very cool what do you tell people the
key to getting out of that is
well first
you've got to submit your finances to
god
capital g capital o capital d submit
your finances to god submit to each
other the accountability
one bank account
one plan one goal one and i'm for us
that was that's a driving factor it's
that accountability that's built in
and then just have
submitting to the process
and
that
that was the thing that for me was
what i don't want to do at dave ramsey's
way
i mean why
who is but it but it was just
saying these things of yeah i can't live
there but i can buy it and just
i mean submit it submit your finest to
god submit to each other
and submit to the process
proven plan
yeah
you two are
both have uh
strong
personalities
so i got a feeling uh just looking at
you i got a feeling the whole putting
the bank accounts together and getting
on the same page was uh a process wasn't
it
when we made that decision to do it it
was easy once we made that decision to
just
go full first but what was actually
interesting is i was still on a bank
account with my mother and it took about
almost a month to go through that
process of taking her off and then
putting him on so there's a little bit
of work involved but once we did that we
realized how powerful both of our
incomes were
together so how's the conversation go on
on selling the motorcycle who brings
that up
well
like you said earlier i was a little
more attached to the motorcycle um i
actually remember the day i bought it
it's for your birthday put it in the
driveway had balloons on it and
everything and i'm calling them every
three minutes why are you coming home
why are you coming home this is a great
wife yeah i think thank you i'll take it
and because i saw this big storm cloud
coming and i didn't want to have to
cover up the motorcycle and he pulls in
the driveway eventually and he says you
know i don't have a motorcycle license
and i'm like what i was like you said
you could drive this thing i'm like i
got online i'm like i'm signing up for
class right now because we are getting
out on the road on this thing so
um yeah too great okay so how did it
come up to sell it who brought it up
well that was something i knew that we
had to do so
i said we can have these things in the
future we can have these nice things
that we want but we have to be in a
position where we're just paying cash
and we're being smart with our money
ding ding there it is so you brought it
up i did okay and tobin what'd you say
you went i can't believe you're doing
this no okay
oh you just said okay okay yeah you were
in it's about that it's about that
shared goal yeah yeah whatever it takes
to get the goal yep yeah that's it
powerful i you know i i we laughed but
but i understand you know he talked you
kept talking about the process you went
to a deep place there the audience heard
it they saw it you submit the process
you know it just that's hard it's very
hard because when you if you get serious
about losing weight or you get serious
about putting on muscle or whatever it
is it is it's the discipline that is so
hard you ask yourself why am i doing
this i remember when dave forced me to
train for the and running the half
marathon like why am i doing this he
forced he shamed me and i have deep
trauma over it
it's another show yeah but i mean
there's something special about
embracing the discipline to get to the
desired future yeah and it's something
that
like
thinking about this is
the process takes time
it's not immediate and for for the
people that have been going through it
for six months six years whatever and
you're still just moving and moving and
moving just be consistent keep going
keep going because
for us it's always
we're planning for for
us at 40 50 beyond yeah and that's
that's the process is it's not immediate
just keep going that's right keep going
yeah we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure you're on
your way how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you will
too and a copy of total money makeover
for you guys to give away to somebody
and get their journey started you guys
are an incredible couple it's fun
talking to you i'm so proud of you
tobin and lindsay atlanta georgia area
paid off 108 000 in 30 months making 150
to 220. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
[Applause]
this is how it's done boys and girls oh
man
grown-up stuff right here on the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 11 1
the lord detests dishonest scales but
accurate weights find favor with him
elizabeth arden said repetition makes
reputation and reputation makes
customers
sounds good
mary's with us in spokane washington hi
mary welcome to the ramsay show
thank you how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
so i am 33 and i am making plans to
leave a abusive marriage
i have two kids
um but i'm really scared and kind of
questioning what i need
moving forward um
i've used your model in the past
we are debt-free but i do have a few
questions on
when i'm a single and come home where do
i need to be placing certain things
i'm sorry
so do you have an income now
i do yes
okay how much do you make
110.
okay
um
why are you still there
you should leave today
i grew up with a single mom and i don't
care don't do a lot of trouble you said
abusive
and once you said abusive you're done
i know
you make a hundred and ten thousand
dollars a year you're gonna be fine i'll
help you we're gonna walk with you but
honey you gotta get out of there you're
saying physical abuse right
yeah well there's a couple things um but
he's gotten treatment i don't care
you've made the decision to leave the
only thing holding you is
stockholm syndrome
i just don't know if i can do it by
myself
that's his that's his words not yours
his words in your head
it's what abusers do they take away your
confidence honey you make 110 000 a year
there's a lot of things you are but
stupid ain't one of them
stupid people don't make 110 a year
what do you do for a living
i work for the government um and i'm a
program manager okay
all right
so you have a steady income and a great
income
yeah why don't you think you can do it
on 110 000 a year in spokane washington
um i just i
haven't made the jump yet and i don't
know whether or not i should buy or rent
a home with the current market you need
a rent
okay because you need to get out of
there this week
you don't have time to buy a home
okay you need to have a sense of urgency
that you don't have now
for the safety of your neck and your
kids
am i wrong
um i'm i feel like we are safe and
why
um
there's certain things that he can't do
now because of
a charge that he's caught and it's um
he's in counseling we're where
counseling kids are in counseling
so um
i'm just what keeps him from doing those
things
a rule
a law yeah
a rule yeah
well there's a rule that happened long
before that rule was put in place that
the rule is you don't hit your wife and
your kids that's a rule
that one didn't occur to him this guy
doesn't follow rules
no
okay
if if you think that the domestic abuse
is over and that the counseling is
working
you wouldn't be calling me
yeah i just i want to figure out how
financially best to
because like i said i was responsible
okay let me restate that and you you
tell me if i'm right
if you thought that he was go that he
was done
and he was getting well and he was
repentant and he was healing from
whatever it is that caused him to do
these things
if you thought that was the case you
wouldn't be calling me asking me how you
were going to end your marriage due to
the fact it was abusive so you don't
think he's better
you don't think he's okay you don't
think he's safe that's why you're
leaving
am i missing something
no i just i've lost trust so although
things aren't occurring now i've lost
that trust and um
i don't want my kids to be further
traumatized and i don't want
them thinking that this is a healthy
relationship right this is how healthy
relationships so you're so you're done
yeah okay there's no reason for you to
stay a minute more mary
what specifically are you afraid of
dave's already told you and he's right
you've got a great income and a great
job what are you scared of because you
called and said i'm preparing to leave
but just like you're needing that nudge
i thought you were going to tell me you
didn't have a job or something what are
you afraid of specifically
well
and anxiety doesn't help but i'm i'm
afraid that um
i'm not going to be enough for the kids
or that my income's not going to be
enough for them and
i don't know
if i'm how old are you
33 okay
and what's your degree in
uh nursing bachelor's nursing okay
all right so
i want you to listen listen i i've got
i've got seven grandbabies and a
daughter your age
okay
and that's the only thing that
authorizes me to say this
so i don't i don't have a i don't have a
uh a doctoral
in counseling like dr john deloney i
don't have any of that but i want you to
listen to me real clearly okay
you
are going to be
an incredible
mother
because you're protecting your children
you are an intelligent lady you're a
smart lady you're a wise lady and you
make a ton of money
you're gonna be just
fine
quit believing the lies that he has told
you that's the trap he put you in
okay you're gonna be fine the kids are
gonna be great
you're gonna do just fine and they're
going to tell the story sometime about
their courageous mom who got them away
from an abusive dad
but you have to do this and you have to
do it right now so here's what we're
going to do
okay because this is not a financial
problem this is an emotional
psychological problem
i am telling you as the the number one
guy in america to advise you on your
money that you have enough money to
leave and you should leave now
and your you can feed your kids in
spokane washington on 110 000
you are fine
they are fine
you are enough
you're going to be a great mom you're
going to be a great single mom you're
going to do great your kids are going to
heal you're going gonna heal you're
gonna look in the rearview mirror and
see this manure in the rearview mirror
but you've gotta put it in the rearview
mirror you're plenty now here's what
we're gonna do i have trained
ramsey certified coaches
in your market
and kelly is going to pick up and we're
going to have you sit down with one
today or tomorrow it's going to cost you
nothing we're going to pay for it
okay
okay and they're going to help you do a
budget and show you how to get your rent
going and show you how to get this stuff
done and i'm going to put you through
financial peace university so you could
be confident on handling money as well
now when you get that level of
confidence in the next three days
i want you to pack your stuff and get
out of there i'm scared for your babies
i'm scared you're gonna hang on and hang
on and hang on and hang on and hang on
because of your lack of confidence that
is completely unfounded and unfactual
does that sound mean
does that sound mean no
no okay
it's just um
embarrassing it's not embarrassing you
didn't do anything wrong
it is embarrassing but you didn't do it
okay
and i want you to hear loud and clear
that you're plenty you're enough
and i want you to feel a ramsay hug
coming through the airwaves right now
and this whole organization is going to
come around you and make your life okay
we're going to show you how to do it you
have the tools to have a great life
okay thank you we believe in you i want
you to call me back on the air and tell
america how that you're okay when you
get the crap out of that house
you hold on and kelly will pick up and
we're gonna get you signed up for
whatever you need
and i hook her up with ken too she'll be
hooked up a kitchen oh she's crushing
she's crushing it what am i saying
put her in everything she needs anything
she needs get it
get her out of the house kelly this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you